ん
[音楽]
両者に行って両親に行って
はいっ
8件多い
楽しくないよ今日初めて社長です今見てもらった通りとんとん相撲ってやったことあり
ますでしょうか
昔は結構やったことあったんですけどもそのなんか台とかで作って土俵とか作って紙を
折って作った人形でこうやって本本トントン行って最後まで通れずに生き残ってた人達
っていうねこう豚ととっと遊ぶトントンと思っていうゲームがあるんですけども[ __ ]
つまんねー
いや正直言うけどにも楽しみがは彼らはやバカないよほとんどときは楽しかったかも
船内をピュッとしたらて僕の24歳になった今実際にやってみると一つはびっくりした
よ大人がやるならて最もダイナミックいることをエクセントにべきどちっくな音あそび
にしたいと思ったので今度はこちらの罪しましたを一緒
今回はこちら見てもらったら分かると思うんですけどミシンでござい
ます人だけます
初めて今回はこちら8男カーン
忘れちゃったよああこれ買った経緯を説明しましょうあの僕やりたかったことがあって
トントン作動が物足りないから
人間など体現できることができないぐらいの混沌のスピードでトントン相撲をやりたい
と思ったのでもうそれは実現しようと思った時何が必要かといったらに
見える早いことトントンの動きが必要だと思いましてそこで民主主義を準備しようと
思って僕あったに行ったんですよねそのアピタねなんかミシンおじさんみたいな人がい
ましてあなたがその時あったり一体何かミシンミシン販売コーナーてね今御宸翰だが今
やでみたいなおじさんのコーナーがあってそこで僕なんか微塵の速度にどんどん
どんどん3人でほとんどするんですけど本当の速さが1
早いミシン撮れなかったかってみてたらおじさんに捕まっちゃって僕なぁその理屈言っ
たわけですよ
一番速度の速い3 c をください千葉このトートの速い潮くださいったら&ぞ意味
不明な顔をしていました何度が僕の言ってる事を理解してもらって勧められたのが
こちらの店でございます俺ねめっちゃ高いからね動画のためだからもしからなかった
けど所に3
維新として使うには高すぎると思います10分の8
z lv 2000てやつですちょっと値段調べは値段は舌出てこないぞ
これひょっとしてやばいの買ったんだねーから価格は基本的にお問い合わせになってる
公式通販のお店があった俺さー
最高のトントン相撲はスタイはケアを
うわぁヨンってマジか
じゃあば8ネットで調べたんですけどもこちらの hz lv 2戦
税込価格17万640円でございます
なんてこったでもねなんかおじいちゃんすごい負けてくれたんって言うんですかなんか
お兄ちゃんせっかく見ずに買ってくれるんだからなんかやすくしていろんなのつけて
あげるよって下に秘境の作りとか防備でぼびぼ女にとって気ボビーも付けてくれたん
ですか
帯で5便とが入ってぼびぼび荷物を入れて北日本ファイト指で史上最強レベルもなった
乗車扱うような速度で虎パンダ弾
どんどんずもできると思うので人間体最高速度のミシンで本当の相撲バトルしていき
たいとおもいます
神まだ実際にこの最強のミシンの速度調べてみますと
何アピタの見知りおじさんが優雅にはこれが最強にはやって言ってからでその二児の母
も戦時でいいと思いますよ俺は取ってくわかんないんだけど
の効果これだ
えっびっくりした急に止めてよこれ足で押せばつくんですけどて手を吸っても動きます
[拍手]
遅いじゃないか何目お店でおじいちゃん行った時はもっとバブ岩盤になってたよ何か
設定のとのこれをいじるのかなぁ
tan
これだこれだ max とか
ウー君人は座部ないので針だけ抜いちゃいましょう
彼だけ抜けました
もう消去受けバッチリはいという気で早速何とかしてフィールドにこいつをセットして
戦わせてみようと思います
me
最高速度で入ってやってみよって
八景おぉおおいどうだ
wh
明け多い残った tre
ジョジョシーナちゃん明日ミシン送っておきますはん
me
うううう
ni
me
あっはぁ